I am tuning a new I'm 31 years old and I
am a filmmaker in Lagos Nigeria
I think that um right from when I was
very young I've always liked the media
my father was a journalist so I mean a
print journalist but then I I would
watch the TV and you know tell myself I
want to be on TV like this person
that's what she does for filmmaking then
it's about storytelling I always get
inspiration to tell stories and they
come to me in different formats so you
know there's some stories that will come
to you and you know that this can work
for radio for example it has to be on TV
or it has to be a documentary there's
some stories that come to you and then I
mean it would just be a film so it was
that was how it started
the europas are one of like the largest
stakeholders in the Nigerian film
industry so I think that the europas uh
it's it's a cultural thing we have this
very beautiful culture we have dance we
have drums we have so it's just natural
that you know would want to do films if
you look at how the current industry
developed it was just about volume
people just kept creating and create and
people loved entertainment people wanted
to watch it you have a lot of filmmakers
as well now who want it to be standard
like we wanted to go places we wanted to
have you know to to have the proper
structure but then we also have
filmmakers who think that or who want
our films to cross you know to the to
the global North and you know for the
world to see because we now need the the
exposure we need the film industry to be
developed so that we'll have you know
people can actually get paid and be able
to live off their earning as creators
for me my hopes and dreams for my career
and industry would be that first of all
to tell stories that very you know
genuine to me you know it's very
important for me to tell stories that I
feel need to be seen by the world